hmm looks like this is going to be one
of the times where we get the black
screen but we'll jump into it we are
today we're chatting with mr. Blaine
Weaver and really so that we're lucky
today then one week we get it we get
some time here with plain um you know it
is work his work that we sort of emulate
ourselves he's a guy that started as an
actor he's you know he's taking sort of
that I'm not gonna wait for other people
to pave the way for me he's doing it
himself he has a beautiful movie weather
girl which we haven't been able to see
yet but we what we do what we do want to
see it yes he has a great sort of role
in official rejection which we did get a
we enjoyed that one and then we were at
the LA premiere of six months roll which
is which is such a beautiful film you
know and it's like it's like wow do we
actually know the guy that made this
film we're sitting there watching it
sits like this is really remarkable
Blaine we thank you for taking some time
out to chat with us about sort of what
you've been able to do and sort of maybe
how that ties into what we're doing now
well thank you those are like the nicest
things anybody's ever said to me and I
appreciate it and I think you're coming
out to see the movie by the way uh yeah
no I'm happy to be here yeah well thank
you and I guess what we want to do here
plan is that he'll put the whole
conversation in perspective um you know
you started on the festival circuit with
weather girl and that's kind of I guess
where we want to start it you know we
want to start the conversation there
because you know you got into some some
major film festivals and then that was
able to roll over into your interests or
and wherever traditional release that
you had success with and we just thought
that would be an interesting place to
start so maybe maybe you can just pick
up there and we'll just kind of you know
pick up on our questions from familiar
no totally well um you know we we we
discussed a little bit before about the
you know film festival theory if that's
the right way to put it but with weather
girl we we were lucky enough to get into
the Slamdance Film Festival
which was a play in place at the same
time at Sundance which is important uh
you know it's great to be acknowledged
artistically by a film festival that's
had some great movies played if that's
awesome but on a business side which i
think is kind of the focus of this
particular conversation it's so useful
to have that platform of park city while
all of the press is there for Sundance
and all that stuff and we were lucky
enough to have some of the talent that
was supporting the movie so we got to
have Mark Harmon and Kaitlin Olson from
Always Sunny in Philadelphia and the
starter show Kelly they all came out to
support it and that was just
immeasurably helpful in getting the
movie looked at twice you know where I
always use this stupid little metaphor
that in the independent film world
you're basically Richie Cunningham and
you need somebody to come and be Fonzie
and put their arms around you and say
hey this kids cool you know and
sometimes it can be a powerful agent
sometimes it can be a big film festival
um but with this particular with weather
girl it was great because Mark Harmon
kind of Fonzie's us in by by being in
Park City and being somebody that people
wanted to interview and he was there to
talk about our movie so suddenly it
wasn't a little movie from some director
nobody had heard of it was mark Harmon's
new comedy so that was a great segue for
us and it's the conversation stopped
being about you know who the hell is
blowing Weaver or you know uh you know
he's a movie any good is none of that it
was all this new comedy that was at park
city and you know people probably
thought mistakenly sundance and blah
blah blah but it was enough to get
attention to the movie and people
actually watched it and gave a damn and
and that's where we ended up getting our
ideals from television and DVD and and
and as part of the sort of the festival
route that you took did it also end up
in at the LA film festival as well did
it did it come down yeah we did a
six-month run basically add Park City we
sold our television rights and we knew
that we were going to be on Lifetime TV
in geez I don't know like October I
think so basically we took six months to
do with the actual run and then part of
our deal with the television deal was we
had a small theatrical window where we
took a portion of the buying money from
the television rights and spent to do
this theatrical so it worked out where
we did six months of festivals then we
premiered in la at the LA Film Festival
and that was the launch of our
theatrical premiere and that next week
we were playing in Los Angeles and then
we went off and did like nine ten other
cities it was really cool getting to
travel the movie and kind of being like
this rolling roadshow you know uh where
sometimes Tricia Oh Kelly the producer
star would go and sometimes I would go
but we were pretty much always
represented whatever town we went to so
we can do a QA and make it a really
personal fun experience and when you
were presented with those offers how
much time were you given to think them
over and read over the contracts I mean
did you have people on the sidelines
there to help you decide what to keep in
the contract of what to keep out yes yes
I find that like it's really funny that
um in my experience with legal
representatives and sales agents and
whatnot um it's rarely been a situation
of like them telling you this isn't the
right deal for you this is not you know
they pretty much want to take whatever
comes especially with a small movie you
know it's like they're taking a huge
chance taking a small movie in the first
place so they want to close a deal
quickly and so our job was always to be
like isn't really what we want you know
I was a huge pain in the ass for my
distributor for my sales agent for
weather girl he did a great job but it
was very much a struggling back and
forth of being like you know but I don't
want it to be a TV movie I wanted to be
in theaters and like them figuring out a
way to make everybody happy which so
seldom works out but it did in that
situation you bet it's always like I
always caution young filmmakers about
the
idea they're gonna be able to hand the
movie to somebody who knows what they're
doing you know as I go here's a sales
rep who knows exactly what they're doing
that may be so but they often though
they want to take care of you they all
they also have this vision of how the
business is about a fine that vision is
broken all the time you know there is no
set way things happen and i think my
career is a is a testament to that and
so you just always got to remember you
can't stop throwing elbows even with
people you were trying to make this
thing into the best possible deal for
you and cast and the investors and all
that net and just to help you know
anyone that isn't familiar like so what
what time frame is this plane like how
helped us bring us at the speed when was
this when was when were you releasing
weather girl and all this happening when
the girl hit Park City Slamdance in 2009
and so that's January and then we opened
in LA in July and then we did I think
was three or four months of that and
then probably around i was in october
november it had its television debut and
then there's a little window there and
then it came out on DVD so that was
pretty much and all throughout all that
time we were doing our theatrical run in
hitting these cities we are raising
money for our next movie which is six
months so what was great was that whole
year was just a whirlwind of weather
girl from january all the way through
and then in February of the next year we
went in production on six month or so
right now the sort of my next question
because were you at thinking like okay
this is not enough to just have it what
it is we need to parlay it to something
else and kind of keep the train moving
we absolutely I think I you know you I
think we always have to be thinking
about the next the next project
especially because there's no one
clamoring you know and saying you know
hey where's your next movie you know you
don't have that the studio on your back
or like handing you scripts or whatever
but a six month rule had been a movie
that I've been wanting to do for a
couple of years and as a matter of fact
I was I had written weather girl as a
spec without intending to direct it and
trishelle Kelly who is the with the star
of my first movie which is a very small
you know very broad comedy that we did
together for less than a hundred grand
and and she read the script to give me
notes and just responded really well
with the material and wanted to you know
put on a producer hat and make it and so
weather girl came together as a huge
surprise to me and because of the
success of that movie made six month
rule which had been kind of my my dream
project happened oh very cool yeah it
was it was great it was very fortunate
it was one of those situations where
weather girl coming together was a two
friends who respect each other immensely
you know being able to join forces and
make something happen which as you know
a lot of times respect is a win
something that's not really in the
scenario here's a suit that's gonna help
me do this thing and you know he hates
my writing and I hate the way he aims
business you know stuff like that this
is not that I've been really lucky with
all of my films actually that we we kind
of come from this indie gritty we're in
this together the movies the most
important thing kind of world thankful I
love it I love it you know and Blaney
just you know it would be helpful you
don't have to go in the exact numbers
here we'll just be helpful to know like
you know from theatrical to DVD and all
the different platforms it was on maybe
just highlight um where where you ended
up getting weather girl like where it
was available and then just maybe a
sense of how how it performed on those
various platforms you know like where
where it perform better you know where
was this pointing that maybe maybe some
information like that well yeah weather
girls a strange bird because we we
basically we we made upper half a
million dollars and then we made pretty
much all of that back on television so
that was great because we got basically
flush now we owed investors one hundred
twenty percent on their investment so
you know they're still like you know
this ticking way of paying back
investors and whatnot and making sure
that everyone's taken care of but even
that was also a time of flux and we're
talking with two years ago but there was
an intense flux in the business model
and the
the way money is paid and so we've had
some problems with the not the movie
getting out there but with making sure
that everyone's adhering to the letter
of the contract and whatnot and we're
still struggling with that you know um I
feel like the little guys are so easily
taken advantage of because we don't have
a machine that has you know 15 well paid
lawyers on the payroll to deal with
every single problem we have one very
cool and talented lawyer who's working
for nothing that I have to get on the
phone with all the time but I mean
that's unfortunately that's part of the
modern world of filmmaking is a you
never can let it go even when it's out
there like we're we're in 30 countries
worldwide right now and that's fantastic
and I love that you know but like trying
to rake in the money owed us for our
investors is is it could be a part time
job it really could be and plus 2 I
think they know how hungry we are even
if you've had several films too and they
know that it's just like okay we've got
to kind of put up or shut up in some
sense because you know this is an offer
that may not come back around or it may
but it made me hard to get the same
offer again so I think they know they
have that advantage as well I'm
wondering what's been the the thing
that's driven the most spikes to see the
film obviously having it on television
is one thing but I mean if you blast
something on social media do you see a
spike in sales or is there interesting
well you know with weather girl was
really funny because the biggest bike we
got was it was stolen like something
like a week before it went on DVD and I
had a kid that works in my office if you
know who's a tech guy and he came in
like all excited that we were like
number four of the most ripped movies
that week and I was just irritated by
the whole thing you know and I didn't
really understand that the next week our
IMDb number like skyrocket like we
suddenly we went from being you know
like 20,000 something to being like I
think we hit nine hundred at one point
and that was before the movie
open on DVD this was all exclusively
people stealing it and talking about it
and I don't encourage it but in that
particular moment in time it actually
helped our our exposure you know and
then months later you know uh months
before it was before lifetime so i guess
it was before it came on television but
when it came on TV that helped to
obviously be you know network TV those
things that we can only dream up with
social media but I mean six months row
it's a little different because we're
we're on video on demand and iTunes and
like the social media really pushes
everything for that oh well thats
interesting news i mean realize that
about weather girl that it got that huge
spike commit you know we're familiar
with ink in the story you know that bad
story you know it's it's a film by Jamie
and Jamie to Cairo winans and and that
one was tired and I think it ended up
like number one on piratebay and and and
so that they had they experienced the
same thing where it shot up I think in
this case it was even he was even higher
and I think it was like in the top it
was pretty it might have gotten as high
as like in the teens it might have been
as high as like number 12 when IMDb and
this is for like a film that had no
marketing budget which is his type
unbelievable so it's funny how things
catch on it certain point isn't it wow
so so you know thank you for helping us
sort of you know create that foundation
you know now we here we are a couple
years later you have six month rule and
so I know from from knowing a little bit
of your story that there were some
things that you learned with weather
girl that you wanted to apply to six
month rule and right now you're sort of
you're still in the early like how long
is the vent it's been about just a few
months that you've been actually
released kinda girl beyond the festival
um you know place there so um can you
can you touch on some of the things that
you that you've learned that you wanted
to put into six months rule and maybe
just give us an update in terms of
what's working so far what's not working
sure yeah well we we open theatrically
June first and one of the one of the
things that I wanted to do with this
film is to make sure that we had a
standard
mode of projection because we've won a
girl two to three years ago every
digital theater had a different kind of
tape they needed they had you know they
they need a hard drive or a digit 80 or
HD cam everything was different and end
up costing us thousands thousands of
dollars to bend over backwards and some
places had to install digital projectors
so I'm like whatever happens we're
getting a 35-millimeter print that's
happening but now so many theaters have
done this DCP thing which is you know a
standard digital projection unit they're
installing all over the country which
has been fantastic for us so we made a
DCP that's what we've been screening
from and that's great and the problem is
that in the three years the independent
film company film theaters are no longer
very independent um three years ago I
could have played all over the country
if I'd had a 35-millimeter print because
they're run by you know guys like me or
like you that are film buffs and like
they use for fun and it's not a great
moneymaker but it's a really cool job
but now so many of the small film
studios uh like you know magnolia
magnolia boned by this company that owns
this huge chain of indie film theaters
and that's the best indie film theater
but they're already booked out from all
the magnolia movies and all the other
you know studios have this time that is
allotted this make sense so there's like
like there's no me schedule in my movie
for three months from now because they
have a movie schedule for three months
from now that you know is a tiny studio
movie and you know look I'm at one of
these people is like you know that's not
an India to studio brah you know it's
like I'm glad the people getting their
movies made you know if I had a movie
made by magnolia I'll feel like you know
it's an independent movie you know
there's not much it costs we were
responsible for anything but but may
always putting it out fantastic but it
does kind of suck that there's not more
of a that we can't get a better shake at
getting some of those screens because
indie studio companies are blocking it
you know I mean that's a thing that
pisses me off does that make sense at
all or I just ramble yeah absolutely i
partially inspired by and what you've
done we got on the phone myself and
Gregor Collins the start of a film
goodbye promise and also producer and
called various theaters in in cities
that we thought oh this would really
resonate with people here whether it be
seattle or nashville or something and
and we asked for percentage deals and
things like that and they said look
there's no stars in this film i hate to
tell you but we can't do that if you
want to rent it for you know six
thousand dollars okay talk and maybe we
could schedule in a few months but we
ran into the same situation so and how
would we ever get to fill a theater in
nashville where we don't know anyone
really and recoup the money that we
could spend a rented so yes it
absolutely makes sense and it was it was
disheartening because it got exciting
you know thinking that we could kind of
take it on the road and as you had done
with with weather girl and and you've
done also with six month rule and so
yeah it's it's if you have deep pockets
it's great but if not it's hard we em we
were going our big plan was to open in
los angeles and then the next week go to
New York and we had to do it backwards
because of theater availability and um
like playing in New York was amazing
like it's a dream that I've always had
you know to have a movie playing there
and like the opening night was awesome
and you know we had to see very casual
party to pub down the street everybody
had a great time you know people I
didn't know people like didn't know it
was amazing i mean saturday just sucked
like it was terrible and like some day
got better again but like this idea of
having to fill a theater is like you
know i don't know if you guys have ever
done plays a theater in los angeles but
it's very akin to trying to get people
to come out and see theater in los
angeles it's like you got to get on the
phone in the morning and start working
it you know what I mean and I it's
another one of those things where you
think at a certain point it's gonna
catch Holden and and go on its own but
it doesn't you just have to keep
hammering
Yeah right yeah we learned that too from
doing our screening series for two years
you know yeah in there were great films
there and it was it was Tom oh yeah 200
plus seat theater it's a whole different
art actually getting people to come and
see the good work you know to me it's a
whole different animal but still part of
it I guess yeah one of our favorite
stories will I think it was um Jeffrey
good men from Phil moviemaker magazine
I'm sorry and every Goodman is from my
home down oh ok so we shot our movies in
the same city oh ok oh very nice that's
right i think we had that conversation
somehow when we did our video interview
with you yeah what brings it up but i
think he he had the tickets with him and
he would say you want to come see my
movie and they be like great and and
then you got ok here's the ticket why
don't we buy it now kind of a thing and
area I feel like that's the way you
gotta do it because so especially la
everybody's so non-committal and I
understand everyone's busy and and it's
a tough city to get to a theater at six
o'clock at night on a Friday Greg but I
almost think that that's the way to do
it I always remember that from him
mm-hmm and I thought that was a great
story love that story yeah yeah I we
might have told this story already but I
really liked this story is that he he
was really good friends with my roommate
when my first film that I wrote manic
came out my man it was playing at the
newton up in new bev somewhere in one of
the small art places in santa monica
anyways he went and saw the movie at
like noon on a tuesday and i was there
and i was just like and he said what are
you doing here it's like oh I you know
got some friends you know that I think
are supposed to be coming so I wanted to
you know meet them have coffee
beforehand or whatever you know kind of
entice them to come he's like yeah but
it's like sing ten o'clock on a Tuesday
what why did this is one mic on I'm here
all the time I've been here for the last
four days good just you know making it
that event you know that like and you
know here's the thing my friends come
and support me by leaving the house and
going you know out of their three-mile
radius and buying it takes the movie
I am happy to get to hang out and you
know have a drink or chat with a friend
who would do that for me that's Frances
no I love that love that yeah you know
anyway so now here we are you opened on
june first you know today it's august
31st how many cities has the film now
played in we did uh seven I went New
York Los Angeles Denver Dallas Lexington
Kentucky ah wait we had one night
screenings in Houston Miami and
unforgettable hometown Westlake
Shreveport and we did a one night
screening somewhere else Oklahoma City
so nine cities six of them were you know
legit week runs a three of them were one
night screening we did that tug thing
which was awesome and got to hit cities
that I couldn't really bring in a whole
week's worth of people but we filled a
theater for the night and got new fans
to the movie and uh you know new people
that are talking about it right now so
it was good i feel really happy with the
way that the actual work and would you
use tug again were you happy with it I
think it's great I think it's great um
yeah it's kind of a win-win to me
because it's like there's nothing really
out of pocket it only happens if you can
fill it so it's like there's no reason
to go to Oklahoma City if I can't sell
you know the minimum tickets would I
think we're 60 tickets you know and we
ended up over selling that like you know
80 ticket so I go to Oklahoma City I
meet these people face to face and uh
again I feel like there's a real sense
of politics to it and that people
remember it means more people if they've
met you you know I'm sure you guys have
experienced that with your film you know
it's just like you them being there and
getting to talk about how this happened
and making it more than just something
you put on your TV but like something
that somebody spent three years doing
you know that you're a part of that you
know what I mean and and i think that's
that's how we try to fill theaters
making an event and does one night
screenings for tug they've been great to
me and and and one thing we haven't
found out yet is I mean what's the
percentage like how did how does the
percentage work with tug like what goes
the tub what goes to the theater what
comes back to the filmmaker I'm still
waiting to see to be honest we you know
we did our contract everything I think
it's like I don't know I looked at it at
one point but I don't remember but the
idea was that we probably won't make
much money on it you know it'll probably
mostly go to the theater and tug but
again we don't lose any money on it and
more people just saw our movie and it
was really cool we got to do a studio
movie grill in Houston which is like an
Alamo Drafthouse which is really fun for
from my movie specifically because
there's a lot of drinking and you know
talking in in my movie and it just
lends itself very much to sitting there
with it with a cocktail I enjoyed it I
purse them I've watch the movie a very
long time yeah but you know if you give
me a cocktail I'll sit there I love them
now you know on our side you know you
know certainly tog is really intriguing
you know I guess for us you know we have
such a small film it was important for
us to just just you know just have it
instantly available you know we just
don't have the means and the resources
to sort of take it city by city as much
as we like to do that we just found on
our side it's just more important to get
the film in front of people where
everyone in the world has instant access
to it and see if we can create some
momentum that way sort of you know build
a snow ball and just push it forward and
see how big it becomes now how do you
feel like it's working how how is the
thing YouTube working out for you I'm
sorry is it on is it on indeed delgo
kickstarter where is it exactly
indiegogo you know that's where it is
all right essentially what we're doing
is we've combined we've taken sort of
indy gogo we're using it as our
storefront yeah this allows us to sell
the film to anyone in the world you know
we were just looking today and we've had
renters come in from Singapore in the
United Kingdom
arab emirate yeah all the stuff you know
Canada you know it's cool it's cool to
see that Austria to just you see like
all these different countries that
people were now have exposure to the
film you know that's really cool to see
and you know we just thought it was our
best shot to go online first you know um
you know one one thing that care now
we're talking about today is often with
crowdfunding it's a way for you to sort
of test your idea like is this a valid
idea right we're responding to this you
know do they want to see this happen and
you know so that's essentially what
we're doing with our release it's like
you know we have a family we don't know
we can't guarantee it's going to get in
any big film festival we can't guarantee
any distributors are going to want it we
can't guarantee anything really but what
we can do is is also but offer to people
and just see if word of mouth bills and
it and as it does we've empowered people
to share it you know so it's like that's
why we couldn't go with the Asheville
first because if people are seeing it in
Kentucky and they want to tell people
about it you know then no one else can
access it at that point in time so it
was just important for us to have it so
it's immediately available everywhere
and ideally we'd love to see it you know
grow so much that there's you know that
people said say it's the cool film love
to see the theater our mindset is you
know for small films like ours basically
start online and see if you see if it
grows and then if it was hard enough
maybe you can have a life theatrically
later on when people want to share in
the experience with you but then that's
the thing it's like just like you know
we were saying there's no set way to do
anything you know what I mean it's like
it's like there's no reason in the world
that can't be a new model that you know
takes off and you does great you know I
wish you guys good luck on it for sure I
wish that we could have done day and
date with the movie in theaters and
video-on-demand itunes because that we
rated the same problem that you know
people want to talk about it and there
was no outlet you know it's just like I
just saw this great movie maybe it'll be
in your town in like three weeks or um
but yeah it's it that same kind of
problem of like all right now you can
tell people and having to go back remind
people remember when
came out to LA and saw that movie okay
now it's on video on demand I tell if I
said that 90 times its repetition we
want demand itunes do you want to do
exactly you know and speakin of that
blade I mean I mean so here you are um
you've hit that you've hit the ground
running you know delivering um two solid
strong excellent beautiful films weather
girl six month rule this has taken place
over the last three years how much of
the audience from weather girl have you
sort of been able to bring along for the
ride and six month woman can any way you
can translate it I mean it does it feel
like does it feel like you've been able
to bring people over for for the new one
absolutely I don't know I mean I feel
like my experience with weather girl I
got to collect a lot of friends of one
level or another you know just by just
by traveling with a movie like you know
film festivals especially you know that
you go and if they like your movie and
you have this great time together that's
a bond that now like with six months
role we play so many almost all of the
festivals that we had played with
weather girl and I believe you know I
believe strongly in the film but I also
believe that for those people I don't
need to be Fonzie din you know they're
gonna look at my movie without and give
me the benefit of the doubt you know
it's like I think that the worst thing
for any filmmaker is for a reviewer or a
screener for festival or anybody to look
at it roll their eyes and put it in you
know expecting it to suck because you
know you can turn it off at any point
you know and just decide that that
sucked and the great thing that I could
literally feel during 6 months rule is
that we were not dismissed by the people
who knew knew us and knew our work they
were just like all right cool let's see
what they did you know and so yes in
that sense absolutely and so I think
vessels the best way to actually track
that because all of these people who had
embraced us for a water girl embrace
this with six months ago and yeah I feel
like you know there are people who are
you know fans of the movie who enjoy
being fans of weather girl because I
you know it's kind of a friend mentality
I think um I'm wondering in terms of
official rejection was there a side
route where people then discovered you
through that because you were great to
watch do people become if they hadn't
for whatever reason I hadn't heard of
you already then seeing official
rejection was there's this sort of
ancillary thing on top of that I
definitely had had some filmmaker I've
made some filmmaker friend to know me
from official rejection and are very
very quick to tell me that they would
have been way more angry that I was and
that I they thought I handled it nicely
but they would have lost it that's what
every filmmaker I say I don't know their
talk about you weren't bad enough I
would have freaked out mmm but yeah
because if you don't know I freaked out
in official rejection because a
screening goes horribly awry very
politely I I did remain polite yeah I
didn't hide my displeasure nothing
that's pure going to that film blame you
know but the thing is that something
good came of it right the fact that paul
osborne shot it was the absolute only
good thing that came out of that weekend
for me oh man but the thing is you know
for anyone like this that's been a
filmmaker for a while and it as has gone
through film festivals you know we've
all experienced something like that at
one point or another it's just if it's
inevitable so the fact that you know
it's captured in this film and and the
way you handle yourself and in just a
whole scenario cool as it sits cure Joey
I hate you know it's this is this is
wonderful to watch earth now what do
they say it's like comedy was it Mel
Brooks comedy is when when somebody else
said your toe you tragedies when you do
it or something like that so that sounds
about right yeah you're saying it was
comedic is that what you're saying
it's with artic too ridiculously comedic
yeah I mean we've all been in situations
like that whether it be with a theater
that screening our film or whatever it
is just that stuff's not going right and
we get to that frustration level so was
it was enjoyable to see someone sort of
in our shoes or other filmmakers shoes
and then I don't know you're able to
sort of process your own stop watching
it yeah we could go on and on about that
you know it's we really enjoyed it you
know we definitely recommend other
people to check that out you know so
playing so here you are um you know so
that is a theatrical run is the council
for one is that is that it for now
forever for what you're doing in
theaters and trap for now we might we
might do Phoenix and there's a tug
screening that might happen but you know
it's going to be sporadic you know one
night screenings based on the interest
of you know the movie-going public that
that's pretty much it we're really
pushing and focusing on you know doing
as well on iTunes and video on demand as
we can and we've been the last couple of
weeks we've been on the top 100 of
rentals in the top 100 in sales on
iTunes which is you know such a cool
thing to see six-month roll up there
between huge movies I was bragging on
Facebook the other day that we beat the
new twilight movie one day and that's
really all I need in life I can put that
if I can if I can outsell on one day at
twilight breaking dawn then my purpose
on this planet has been fulfilled nice
do you think that then tug is an
alternative to film festivals in that
maybe you don't get really much money in
you know in your pocket and you might
have to shell out money for travel and
for hotel costs but you really spread
the word and if it's just a one-night
screening you know maybe you're gonna
spend a hundred dollars to enter a film
festival why not spend a hundred dollars
on a laquinta inn you know room or
something yeah I think it's possible I
think the biggest problem is that it
doesn't come with a built-in audience
like most on faith festivals do you know
it's like um
I could go to say Oklahoma City and do a
tug screening because I've played the
dead center film festival there like
three times so I know a bunch of people
there only because of that festival but
if I just like said I played the Omaha
film festival with six month roll and
I'd never been to Omaha before and we
had a pact screening and that was based
you know I guess people like the picture
and the synopsis and they bought a pass
to a festival so they're gonna go see
something you know what I mean I
couldn't have filled the theater in
Omaha for the life of me but now I feel
like I've got a bunch of friends in
Omaha if I do another film and don't go
to the festival I would totally do it
Doug screening there you know try to
reach out to those people who had
supported me before okay so you don't
feel it's an answer for film festivals
but in conjunction with spreading your I
think so I think so i think that the the
best i think by far the best thing about
festivals it's always fun to you know go
and you know feel important for weekend
you know actually guy i always have a
good time but the real point i think is
to get your film out there and to get
people to see it and if they like it
they don't forget that they liked it if
they saw on the festival known i mean
it's like how people forget things all
the time if they rented or so on HBO or
above a blob but if you went there and
you met the guys and you saw the QA and
then you voted on what level you thought
the movie was you know that's not
something that's really going to leave
you it's a shared experience with the
filmmaker and with the movie you know
that that I think you know in 10 years a
when this movie is playing on cable they
can see that and say you know I saw that
movie at the Omaha film festival 2012
and that guy got so drunk yo so good I
didn't that was a joke uh I was very
responsible and so so so now it is
available on iTunes where else is where
else can we see it now it has a hint VOD
as well it's on VOD so it's probably on
your cable provider
now you can see it on iTunes you can see
it on freakin voodoo or Playstation or
Xbox everywhere the digital platform
goes you can watch it there and and so
when does your work slowdown in terms of
you know being behind it actively you
know cuz obviously you're not attending
screenings now but how much more work do
you do in terms of social media emailing
and all that kind of stuff to continue
to spread the word I mean that you were
at the point now were you pretty much
backing off of it well I thought I would
be um but it just keeps um it just keeps
going like my my lead actress natalie
morales and i shot a little promo
interview like two days ago that today
when i got caught up and was late for
this I was cutting at the production
office so that I could get it to the
distributor so that they could get it
out to their social media things and so
it's not just me all the time but yeah
it's all the time it's all the time and
always you know continually pushing you
know and it's a on one hand to it's a
huge pain in the ass but on the other
hand it feels like it's the least that
the work deserves you know so I don't
know where the line is I I would like to
get to a point where I can start working
on the next film and just bury myself in
that and let six month rule you know
continue on and it's a snowball
snowballing to use your metaphor kind of
way or just keep getting bigger and
bigger until it destroys old towns I
don't think is the appropriate time uh
to let it snowball until you start with
the next project well it's probably
exactly the amount of time it takes me
to get another project off the ground it
probably will be exactly that but but
yeah I've got a you know a script that I
really want to make and it's just about
getting six month fool to a point where
I can turn around the say this is what I
did with the last movie you know let's
do another movie and I feel like we're
on
there we're almost to a place where
anybody no matter how Fonzie they are
can look at the track record of six
months rule and say hey awesome big
success you know theatrical great review
from variety itunes top 100 you know
blah blah blah we're supposed to come
out on blu-ray around November so
that'll help things but but that's it
it's always about trying to get to this
point where you're the film success is
undeniable that that's what makes make
in the next movie easy I guess like with
leather girl that's what made it
possible everybody could see okay this
is doing well you know here's how much
money made here's how many theaters of
play there it is on TV boom you know um
let's make another one so that's what we
need to do with six months rule so that
we're not you know well what just moving
on to another project before we fully
put this one to bed and is it living up
to the expectations and the projections
you had before you finally release this
thing publicly yeah I mean I think so I
mean you know it's like numbers are so
difficult you know because they're like
quarterly and less than then educational
for a guy like me i'm not i'm not really
a numbers guy you know but as far as the
rollout uh artistically I couldn't be
happier I love the fact that the movie
is right next to you know huge films in
I respect I love that you know you can
choose between you know my movie or the
new George Clooney movie right next to
each other you know I mean that that is
so fulfilling uh it's like you don't now
people have a chance to see it and
there's nothing more frustrating than
having something you're proud of and
this sitting on it and being like well I
have this movie but it's really
difficult for you to see it so I'll just
tell you about it that's really not the
way you want to do it you want it to be
this thing which is happening now where
people we have a conversation about it
at coffee and then the next morning I
got a call but they watched it at home
in bed put it put it on the
the man and watched it that's awesome
and I've never had an experience like
that with with a movie you know it's
either been on television where it plays
if their schedule or you know DVD where
it's like oh yeah order that you
probably won't order it you know most
people don't but uh but with video new
man in itunes it's super easy and people
really take advantage of it you know I
we're getting ready to let you go here
Blaine and we thank you for your time
I'm just curious though you know we got
into a little conversation on Twitter a
couple days ago and in and then all of a
sudden today we put up there because you
know antenna from our point of view
we're offering our film for one dollar
you know that this is the world release
and we're we're just really trying to
have our entry into the world you know
we had a previous film that we made it
really hasn't been seen by that many
people I really hadn't sold a lot we
weren't able to get it up onto all these
platforms and so now with this film with
it's so small and we have the luxury of
being able to release it the way we are
and so it's interesting we've off we're
offering it for a dollar in so far you
know we've averaged between basically
between seven and eight dollars per
person so even though it's available for
a dollar the standard contract is that
school is two dollars just just
wondering your point of view in terms of
this one dollar price point for Indies
ah I don't know I don't know I don't
really know that world that well I'm you
know I did certainly not my strong suit
but you know what i think this i think
if people are watching it that's the
goal you know and if being it at one
dollar will bring more people into to
buying it then I i support the hell out
of it you know I think whatever gets
asses in the seats you know to to sit
there and see your work um you know I've
been this close to paying people to go
sit you know um but no I think I think
that's fantastic and I think you know
this the cool thing about independent
film whether it's the filmmakers or the
fans of it it's like we tend to stick
together you know it's like you see it a
lot on Kickstarter you see a lot and you
know film festivals and whatnot it's
like there's
a group mentality of like a rising tide
raises all ships I like that very much
because it's very not the rest of the
Hollywood System but you know in the
indie world it does seem to be that and
it doesn't surprise me at all the people
are you know donating more than the
minimum you know recommended amount for
something that you put your blood sweat
and tears into I think that's cool um
you know I I'm not sure how close you
looked at what we've done I mean just on
across if you have any questions or any
ideas or thoughts um in terms of what
we're doing um well i'm going to buy
your film today and i'm going to give
you way more than maybe sit no i can't
wait to see your film so i'm gonna do
that but the i don't know i think it's
cool i really want you to keep me up to
date on how it goes and everything
because i love seeing these these new
models arise um because you know I it
just so many people have told me that
I'm doing it wrong at different points
in my in my process and I just really
don't I really love that you guys don't
listen to that you know any naysaying
whatever you've got your movie out there
and that's a huge accomplishment and you
know and you were Fonzie by la time
which is just cool you know so you got
the prestige and now you're getting out
there and you know getting the actual
people to see it which i think is the
goal right I think that's fantastic and
do you think more clear enough in what
we're doing i know we had someone that
kind of let us know which is actually
very helpful online and he said you know
you might want to be more clear in your
description about that it's an online
release that you're not a crowdfunding
for like another film is there a polite
way to like a gracious way to kind of
say that on the IndieGoGo page so that
we know like instead of like you know
please be advise or something but just
to let people know this is an online
release I don't know I got it I got I
got that you guys are doing that I never
like that's why i was confused that it
was own i forgot that it was on
indiegogo because I knew it wasn't
raising money for something else you
don't even um but I mean I I'm getting
it it seems like it's working for me oh
we weren't sure how out win and we were
actually happy that the person brought
that up to us because that was helpful
so oh yeah it's incredibly helpful
because like I I've had so many people
contact me about all of the digital like
anything online itunes you know i think
you know one of you guys might have had
something to do with saying hey how come
it says director unknown on itunes I
hadn't noticed that so you know all
these things that Mike my friends fresh
eyes you know looking at something that
I just figured well it's small you know
actually you know but then I realized
all these other small movies have their
directors listen when I was my name
listed right but I wouldn't have done
that it's like paul osborne if somebody
hadn't been like you know hey once you
haven't put your name on there dude yeah
so like another guy told me the other
day that on voodoo were not listed in
the film buff collection which film buff
desire distributor so that was silly so
that was an easy phone call to make I
just hadn't noticed that it was a thing
and I've been really grateful to have a
bunch of people trying to watch my back
during this thing which is great and it
sounds like you do as well oh very cool
well we love it you know bleh we're
apparently grateful for you we're
grateful for your time we encourage
everyone out there to go see six month
rule it's just it's beautifully done
it's well written to 12 active it's
impressive work it really is you so much
thank you so much and I really
appreciate this and you know he'll
everybody check it out on itunes and
i'll talk to you guys soon thank you so
much it's just real quick when we
haven't been able to see whether girl
yet we like to do that what's the best
way to see it to support you whatever's
easiest for you can see it on itunes oh
you can rent the movie from netflix you
can it's each streaming all over the
place and you know amazon has them for
sale so uh oh is it on amazon on demand
do I believe it is yes hey hey dudes on
Amazon streaming that's the same thing I
think is okay
great um yeah so what we're gonna we're
gonna let our things settle down here
yet but that's sort of a movie that we
have on our list that we need to get to
so awesome awesome alright well and I
will talk after I see your film I can't
wait all right okay thank you so please
show the boy thank you so much guys all
right take care